[Musique]
nous allons vous raconter l'histoire
oubliée de la présence française en
Amérique du Nord pendant presque 200 ans
on a cet immense territoire la
nouvelle-fance et puis un jour
brusquement la France s'en est éloignée
et nos mémoires en ont effacer la
trace s'il revenait parmi nous qu'en
penserait les coureurs des bois les
explorateurs soldats marins et
administrateurs les femmes et les hommes
qui ont écrit l'histoire de la
nouvelle-fance français nous connaissons
l'histoire des colons anglais du
Mayflower mais nous ignorons celle des
Acadiens qui plusieurs années avant eux
s'était déjà installés sur la terre
d'Amérique nous connaissons le nom de
Lafayette qui aida les États-Unis à
conquérir leur indépendance mais nous
faisons la passe sur Robert Cavelier de
La Salle qui 100 an avant lui descend le
Mississippi jusqu'au golfe du Mexique
nous faisons l'impasse sur ces
explorateurs qui repoussant vers le sud
et vers l'ouest les limites de la
nouvelle-fance s'aventure jusqu'au
et au contrefort des Montagnes
Rocheuses dans la peau d'un voyageur de
l'Amérique française j'ai voulu réparer
l'injustice de l'oubli et rendre hommage
à cette extraordinaire épopée j'ai voulu
transmettre de l'Intérieur l'émotion des
rencontres et revivre la découverte d'un
espace infini ù sur des millions de
kilomètres carrés français et nation
indienne partager le même
[Musique]
destin
mes premiers pas me conduisent vers la
forteresse de Louisbourg construite ici
pour protéger les avant-postes de la
Nouvelle-France et sa capitale Québec
située à un millier de kilomètres à
l'intérieur des
terres positionnée entre Terreneuve au
nord et la ville de Boston au sud celle
qui fut en son temps la plus grande
place forte militaire du continent
nord-américain devient dès sa
construction un important carrefour de
négocce et de commerce au confluents des
grandes routes de
[Musique]
l'Atlantique sentinelle endormie Louis
bourg n'oublie pas son histoire elle se
souvient
[Musique]
elle se souvient que derrière ses
remparts de pierre et le va et vient de
ses garnisons elle était une ville
française
[Musique]
d'Amérique
traversé par l'onde de la mémoire Louis
Bour sort parfois de son silence et
ranime son
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
âme B poies la VI cadienne il y a
beaucoup de cette musique là qui vient
de la France la plupart vient de la
France peut-être qu' a été adapté la
mélodie évolue peut-être des paroles qui
changent mais j'ai vraiment l'impression
des fois de faire reviv des fois je me
pose la question est-ce que probablement
que quelqu'un a chanté cette chanson ici
il y a de siècles et demi de siècles
passé et s'il y avait un habitant de
Louisbourg du 18e siècle qui revenait
puis qui me rencontrait puis qui
m'écoutait chanter la chanson estce qui
reconnaîtrait la musique la mélodie dit
les paroles est-ce que ça leur plairait
ou
non des fois j'ai même l'impression
quand je des fois je suis tout seul il y
a personne sur les lieux mais j'ai même
l'impression d'entendre quelqu'un
chanter avec moi des fois j'ai
l'impression de per de Nour un peu perd
la tête come on dit mais des fois j'ai
l'impression que j'entends des voix qui
chantent avec moi tandis qu' personne
c'estou
les vient pour
faire avant de retrouver la solitude de
son éloignement Louis Bour se souvient
aussi de son port qui il y a un peu plus
de de siècles était le plus grand de la
nouvelle-
[Musique]
France ma route me conduira ainsi sur
des traces qui traversent les anciennes
terres
où il y a 4 siècles des Français ont
découvert un nouveau
[Musique]
monde c'est au printemps 1604 sur la
côte est de l'Amérique du Nord que
l'histoire des Français d'Amérique
commence cette terre s'appellera
l'Acadie
accompagnant l'expédition celui que l'on
surnommera plus tard le père de la
nouvelle-fance Samuel de champelin
explore et cartographie la région tout
en participant à la fondation du premier
établissement français dans le Nouveau
Monde traversant les tourments de
l'histoire l'acadiie ne cesse de
renaître de ses cendres blotti dans un
Canada maritime du bout du monde la
petite communauté acadienne de cheétican
préserve ici derrière une immense
étendue de forêt son identité et sa
langue française
arrivé au 18e siècle les descendants des
12 familles fondatrices sont aujourd'hui
plus de 4000 les jeunes élevés dans
l'amour de leur culture d'origine se
transmettent les musiques et les
chansons de génération en génération
pour inlassablement partager la fierté
qu'ils ont d'être
acadien Robert Devau de Louisbourg à
chétican où il vit veille sur la mémoire
de son
peuple c'est vrai qu' certaine fierté je
veux dire parce que sans se casser la
tête sur la question c'est quoi un
acadien qu'est-ce que c'est que l'Acadie
et cetera on est quand
même un peuple d'une certaine façon
distinct on a notre propre dialect on a
notre propre jargon on a faut quand même
se féliciter d'avoir probablement
félicité nos anes nos parents nos
grands-parents nos grandparents ainsi de
suite d'avoir sur résister à la tendance
à l'assimilation vers l'anglais parce
que c'est un phénomène au Canada tous
les autres immigrants qui viennent au
Canada finissent par apprendre à parler
anglais la
plupart
mon comme un en qui
é résistant aujourd'hui les jeunes de
chétian puis leurs forces et les
conviction dans l'amour de leur langue
et de leur
histoire dans les quatre provinces
atlantique du Canada de Terreneuve à la
nouvelle- Écosse les Acadiens sont plus
de 300000 chacun dressé avec son
bouclier de mémoire et d'héritage pour
survivre à l'assimilation
[Musique]
anglophone dès leurs premières
explorations en Amérique les Français
comprennent que le fleuve Saint-Laurent
leur ouvre les portes de l'intérieur du
continent après plusieurs
reconnaissances il décide de s'établir
dans un lieu que les Amérindiens
appellent dans leur langue Québec là où
le fleuve se resserre c'est à cette
endroit que le 3 juillet 1608 Samuel de
champelin qui accompagne la petite
expédition française de quelques
dizaines d'hommes fonde la ville qui va
devenir la capitale de la
[Musique]
Nouvelle-France 400 ans plus tard Québec
deviendra une ville de 500000 habitants
le journal de voyage du Père François
Xavier de charlevois daté du 28 octobre
1720 lève le voile sur le passé français
de la petite capitale on ne compte guère
à Québec que 7000 âmes mais on y trouve
un petit monde choisi où il ne manque
rien de ce qui peut former une société
agréable les Canadiens respirent en
aissant un air de liberté qui les rend
fort plaisant dans le commerce de la vie
et nulle part ailleurs on ne parle plus
purement notre langue on remarque même
ici aucun accent 28 octobre
1720 c'est ici vraiment né la
nouvelle-fance française Québec est
vraiment la ville où la présence
française est continue depuis le 3
juillet 1608 donc c'est pour ça que il y
a ici un cœur Français qui bat qu'on ne
retrouve nulle part ailleurs pourtant le
développement de la ville de Québec est
extrêmement lent 30 ans après sa
fondation en 1640 sa population dépasse
à peine quelques centaines d'habitants
si bien que la survie de la petite
colonie dépend presque entièrement de la
coexistence entre français et
amérindien dès le dès les débuts de
l'histoire de la Nouvelle-France il y a
des relations extrêmement forte entre
les Amérindiens et et les Français c'est
des Amérindiens qui nous ont appris
comment par exemple être capable
d'attraper un animal lorsqu'on est perdu
comment on est capable de faire un feu
en forêt ainsi de suite et on se sent
beaucoup plus près des amériens que les
anglophones peuvent se sentir il y a
plusieurs décennies c'était une on de
dire qu'on avait par parmis ses ancêtres
un autochtone mais depuis quelques
décennies bon nombre de Canadiens
français bon nombre de Québécois se
cherche en généalogie êre avoir parmi
leurs cêtres un Amérindien et là on est
tout fier de dire je descends d'un
sauvage si dès les premiers échanges les
Français du Canada éprouvent de réelles
affinités avec les populations
amérindiennes cette volonté de
rapprochement n'est pas non plus dénuée
de tout calcul géopolitique les Français
comprennent en eff qu'ils ont tout à
gagner dans ce rapport de confiance et
de loyauté qu'il tissent avec
patience en s'immergeant dans la société
amèreindienne ils en étudient les
langues qu'ils traduisent puis
transcrivent dans des dictionnaires
franco-indiens qui facilitent et
renforcent la communication et
l'intimité les savent aussi que sur le
plan militaire la nécessité d'une
alliance indienne est l'unique moyen de
faire face à la très béliqueuse et toute
proche Nouvelle Angleterre dont les 13
colonies sont largement plus peuplé que
la nouvelle-fance c'estàdire que pour un
habitant de la Nouvelle France du Canada
il y en avait 20 en Nouvelle Angleterre
de sorte que il y avait un genre de
disproportion mais malgré cette
disproportion là les Anglais Angleterre
craignait énormément les Canadiens parce
parce que on était assz cruel faut pas
oublier que euh nos ancêtres ont scalpé
comme les indiens l'ont fait
hein a il y a pas de soldat anglais qui
vont faire des raides pendant l'hiver
mais il va quand même y avoir au début
du 18e siècle des Canadiens qui vont
partir en raquette et qui vont faire des
des des centaines de kilomètres pour
aller attaquer de nuit des villages de
la Nouvelle Angleterre et et là
exactement faire le le cri euh comme les
Indiens faisaient
là et après ça attaquer en pleine nuit
brûler les maisons et parfois tuer des
femmes et des
enfants en épousant les murs et les
usages autochtones certains Français du
Canada s'indianisent et au contact des
montagniers ou des Algonquins des Hurons
ou des utaw il s'éloigent du cœur de la
colonie pour mener la vie nomade du
coureur des
bois au même moment tout autour de
Québec la vallée du Saint- commence à se
peupler les Canadiens français qui
choisissent de se sédentariser
s'établissent le long du grand fleuve
qui devient l'axe de communication
principale de la
Nouvelle-France comprenant l'intérêt
qu'ils ont de fonder une nouvelle ville
au cœur du continent les Français qui
ont parfaitement bien assimilé
l'importance du système hydrographique
du pays choisissent l'emplacement de
Montréal
au centre des voies fluviales qui reli
d''est en ouest l'océan Atlantique au
grand lac le site ouvre des perspectiv
commerciales qui préfigurent les futurs
échanges entre l'Amérique et
l'Europe Montréal dès sa création
devient un intense Carrefour d'affaires
où converge marchand français amérindien
ressentant intuitivement l'importance
symbolique de ce point de rencontre ses
fondateurs rêvent d'en faire la première
ville franco-indienne de l'histoire
Montréal est fondé en 1642
c'est Paul chaodé de maison neuve et
jeunems qui arrivve qui sont en mission
on leur a donné la mission la société de
Notre-Dame de Montréal les envoyé ici
pour fonder une ville essentiellement
dans le but de de fonder une colonie
mixte de mixage si on veut entre
Français et amérindien alors c'est très
particulier c'est c'est vraiment propre
à Montréal
le rêve des fondateurs ne se réalise pas
la ville sera française avant de devenir
métropole canadienne dès le début
pourtant les Amérindiens y viennent en
nombre mais ils en repartent aussitôt
Montréal est uniquement pour eux le lieu
de vente du produit de leur chasse tout
comme il l' pour les voyageurs ces
commerçants de la fourrure qui vont et
viennent à l'intérieur du
continent il me semble que les canaux
était était rangé là comme ça en de
manière perpendiculaire au rivage exact
imaginez ici il y a 200 ans des canaux
qui sont accostés tout le long des
berges et ce sont les canaux qui vont
que les voyageurs vont prendre pour
quitter vers les territoires de traite
donc on quittait au printemps aussitôt
que les glaces allent fondes on appelait
ça le grand départ parce qu'il y avait
tellement d'hommes qui se rassemblit ici
pour quitter on quitte en brigade une
brigade c'est 10 canaux 10 Canau sans
hommes et on quittait dans les
meilleures années jusqu'à 10 brigades à
la fois donc on parle de 100 canaux 1000
hommes et ensuite on va se diriger vers
la rivière des outaw la Matawa le le lac
Nipissing la rivière des Français la
baie Georgienne les Grands Lacs et on
continue jusqu'au bout nord nord-ouest
du lac Supérieur on peut dire des des
centaines et des centaines de de
kilomètres 1800 km
environ donc en 45 jours c'est c'est
c'est pas mal de travail on travaille
environ 16 he par jour lar salé poiss
sec farine biscuit les voyageurs
transportent leurs provisions pour
parcourir l'espace canadien à la force
de leurs
bras ils s'enfoncent au cœur des tribus
indiennes dont ils ont appris les
langues respectent les coutumes et les
les croyances et avec lesquelles il
partagent le même territoire sauvage
ainsi nommé le pays d'en
haut on on on a tendance à penser que la
forêt canadienne est vide et puis que le
voyageurs pouvait parcourir cette
distance là sans jamais voir un être
humain c'était pas vrai les forêts sont
remplies de de de de de différentes
nations qui habitent partout et qui vont
même aller voir les voyageurs ils savent
qu'il vont que les voyageurs vont passer
au printemps qui vontevenenir à l' ils
vont à leur rencontre et ils vont leur
apporter des fourrures pour échanger
cont différentes choses vont même
apporter de la nourriture des fois du
miel des des des petits fruits pour pour
faire du troc par exemple avec des
effets personnels des voyageurs donc
c'est il va toujours avoir des
rencontres de de de autant de de de gens
d'ascendance française ou de Canadiens
avec des différentes nations
[Musique]
ici
on retrouve énormément d'animaux à
fourrure dans les forêts canadiennes on
voit ici le
castor qui va être prisé pour son feutre
pour faire les chapeaux de feutre on a
ici du laveur du du chat sauvage
aussi on dit la même chose on a ici de
la
loutre la loutre qu'on retrouve dans
l'eau également et du renard et ça ce
n'est que des exemples des types
d'animaux qui est attrapé pour le
commerce de la fourrure on va attraper
tout ce qu' a une fourrure du lièvre de
la mouffette du loup de l'ours du plus
gros gibier comme du SER comme de
l'orignal tout ça seraattrapé parce que
c'est très en demande pour la mode en
Europe partout en Europe ben c'est ça
parce que je sais qu'à Paris dans les
années 1710 on aimait la loutre en 1720
on préférait le laveur donc ça
change ça évolue et vous ici alors le le
le commerce change en fonction de de la
mode qui est décidée à Paris absolument
la raison qu'on a le commerce de la
fourure d'abord et avant tout c'est à
cause de la mode de l'autre côté de
l'Atlantique c'est un commerce qui a
lieu à cause de ce qui se passe là-bas
et puis l'offre et la demande ça do
toujours existé donc si pendant une
décennie le renard est très à la mode il
est très en demande et puis la lutre les
moins mais là ça va affecter comme quels
animaux qui seront attrapés ici ça va
affecter les les les échanges dans les
postes de traite également tributaire de
la demande l'économie de la fourrure
dépend avant tout de ses sources
d'approvisionn et de l'acheminement des
PO jusqu'à Montréal or les nations
irocoises allié des Anglais menacent les
communications et les routes fluviales
de la nouvelle-fance conscient du danger
les Français veulent à tout prix éviter
l'affrontement avec les redoutables
guerriers iroois subtilement il
privilégie la voix de la
diplomatie les Français ressentent le
besoin un moment donné de de de calmer
le jeu à l'intérieur du continent et de
demander aux Iroquois de ne de ne pas
aller à l'encontre de leurs propres
activités commerciales alors il demande
une espèce de de neutralité quand il y
aura des des des altercations par
exemple entre français et anglais ils
vont demander aux Iroquois ce qui était
déjà en soi un geste assez audacieux ils
vont leur demander de de ne pas
intervenir s'organise alors une série de
négociations et de pourparler cherchant
à montrer au zirokois la diversité et la
puissance de leurs alliances les
Français convoquent à Montréal la
plupart des nations du continent les
Hurons d'abord leurs plus fidèles alliés
mais aussi les Siou les renards les cris
et les Algonquin tous faisant pression
sur les iroois pour qu'ils acceptent la
Grande Paix proposée par la France
pendant tout le mois d'août 1701
Montréal devient la capitale des Indiens
d'Amérique Montréal à l'époque est une
petite ville d'environ 1200 habitants
l'arrivée des délégués à mindiens va
faire plus que que doubler cette
population là pendant une période très
courte de de quelques semaines de trois
ou 4 semaines donc il faut imaginer ce
que ça pouvait représenter pour pour les
Montréalais de voir arriver c'est une
rencontre internationale à l'échelle de
l'époque c'est vraiment ça c'est une
rencontre internationale c'est une
conférence internationale de paix et
donc il a des langues multiples et les
Français vont mettre vont déployer leur
arsenal de traducteurs alors il y a des
missionnaires il y a des coureurs des
bois il y a des officiers qui qui ont
appris les langues parce que ça prend
des gens qui sont capables de traduire
toutes ces languesl il y a au moins 37
ou 38 représentants de nations
différentes après plusieurs semaines de
négociation la paix est ratifiée et au
mois de septembre 1701 les représentants
de chacune des nations apposent la
marque de leur tribu au bas du traité au
niveau diplomatique la Grande Paix de
Montréal est un fait unique dans
l'histoire de la
c'est aussi un extraordinaire succès
politique pour le gouverneur de la
nouvelle-fance Louis Hector de
callaliierre qui réussit à mettre un
terme au conflit interethnique des
Amérindiens alors va leur demander si
vous avez des problèmes entre vous vous
ne vous vous ne réglerez pas vos
problèmes vous-même vous venez me voir
alors c'est la première fois qu'un
Français gouverneur français devenait un
espèce de médiateur auprès des
communautés des nations améindiennes
laisse le champ libre au français pour
pénétrer à l'intérieur du
[Musique]
continent jamais la Nouvelle-France ne
peut se maintenir s'il y a pas l'appui
amérindien et ça c'est je crois que dans
l'histoire on on commence à peine à à
ramener le le rôle des Amérindiens le
rôle actif qu'on joué les Amérindiens
dans la dans la construction de
l'histoire canadienne et naméricaine il
est
fondamental en quittant Montréal pour
suivre la route des Grands Lacs il
revient à ma mémoire le journal de
voyage de François Xavier de charlevois
pendant les 2 ans où il parcourt la
nouvelle-fance l'historien soulligne la
dignité des peuples autochtones voici ce
qu'il écrit le 8 août 1721 quelque part
en pays indien dans ce pays tous les
hommes se croient également hommes et
dans l'homme ce qu'ils estiment le plus
c'est l'homme nulle distinction de
naissance nulle prérogative attribué au
rang qui porte atteinte au droits de
chacun point de prééminence qui inspir
l'orgueil et qui fassent trop sentir aux
autres leur infériorité il y a peut-être
moins de délicatesse dans les sentiments
que parmi nous moins de façon équivoque
mais plus de droiture moins de ses
retours sur soi-même
8 août
les Français sont venus ici pour
évangéliser les Wanda le peuple
Huron les prêtres jésuites all vivre
dans des villages Wanda et s'imprégner
de leur culture de leur langue et de
leurs
croyances ici à Sainte-Marie les
Français sont venus armer de bonnes
intentions mais avec le recul de
l'histoire il y a d'autres aspects à
prendre en compte il a beaucoup de
conséquences dramatiques lié à l'arrivée
des Français ils ont aussi introduit
tout srie épidémie de variol de
rougeoles et de
grippe j'ai trouvé le village des
arcansas dans la dernière désolation il
y a quelques temps un Français passant
par ici fut attaqué par la petite
verrole le mal s'est communiqué d'abord
à quelques sauvages et bientôt à toute
la bourgade le cimetière paraît comme
une forêt de perche et de poteau
nouvellement planté toute la nuit j'ai
entendu pleurer les hommes s'enmêlent
aussi bien que les femmes j'ai aussi
aperçu le soir une femme qui pleurait
sur la tombe de son fils et qui a allumé
du feu apparemment pour réchauffer le
mort le choc microbien SVIT partout
d'environ 7 ou 8 millions vers 1600 la
population indienne de l'Amérique du
Nord passe à moins d'un million 200 ans
plus
tard ce sont les conséquences de
l'histoire il faut se faire une raison
prendre ce qu'il y a de bien mais aussi
ce qu'il y a de mal il faut pouvoir
juger his dans son ensemble mais vous
pensez que les Jésuites ont introduit
les maladies volontairement non
absolument pas les missionnaires sont
venus ici avec de bonnes attentions ils
sont venus en pensant faire le bien ils
sont venus pour apporter leur religion
et leur foi mais aussi pour
enseigner c'était le fond de leur action
les prêtres étaient avant tout des
enseignants ils propessaient leur
culture mais aussi celle des Hurons il y
avait un échange des cultures chaque
peuple se nourrissait des connaissances
de l'utre c'est bien qu'ici en Ontario
mais partout dans le Canada il y a eu
beaucoup de métissage avec les Français
et cela s'est passé aussi à Sainte
Marie en témoignant pour son peuple Paul
retrace avec pudeur la réalité de
l'histoire qui si elle provoque l'un des
plus grands drames de l'humanité le
génocide microbien des Amérindiens fait
aussi naître l'immense espoir d'un
nouveau peuple les
Métis
avec le développement du commerce de la
fourrure de plus en plus de Français du
Canada quittent la vallée du
Saint-Laurent pour tenter l'aventure de
[Musique]
l'Ouest plus ils s'éloignent de leur
société d'origine plus leur lien avec
leur passé se
distend souvent en pays indien ils
prennent une ép
fondent une famille et s'établissent là
où le destin les a porté l'île de
Manitoulin au milieu des Grands Lacs a
longtemps été une terre de métissage où
français et Amérindiens s'unissaient
pour devenir un même
peuple nous trouvons ici dans la réserve
indienne de Manitoulin et comment se
fait-il àin Corbière que vous soyez
autochtone et qu'en même temps votre nom
soit
français bon il y a pas mal de raisons
mais l'une d'entre elles est que dans
les années 1700 et le début des années
1800 beaucoup de personnes ici avaient
un père français le nom c'est donc
transmis ici les descendants de mariage
mixte ne sont pas vraiment considérés
comme des métises ils sont michinabé
comme tout le monde c'est-à-dire
autochtone tout le monde vit dans la
réserve et a grandi ici tout le monde
est allé à l'école ici et tout le monde
fait partie de notre peuple minabé qu'il
soit métis ou
pas
maist plus je progresse à l'intérieur de
l'Amérique du Nord et plus je me sens
confronté à la question d'une Amérique
française alliance indienne commerce de
la fourrure choc microbien peuple
métisse le Français d'Amérique est le
témoin sans le savoir d'un monde en
transition pendant 150 ou 200 ans il
côtoie une Amérique indigène dont il ne
sait pas encore qu'elle est sur le point
de disparaître intermédiaire entre deux
mondes et entre deux moments de
l'histoire il se laisse porter par les
fleuves et par l'espace il communi avec
la terre d'Amérique comme le peuple
amerindien lui a appris à le
faire et s'il laisse parfois ses noms et
sa langue en traversant l'immensité il
n'est que de passage la nouvelle-fance
qu'il transporte avec lui est un rêve
nomade dont la mère nature est l'unique
[Musique]
croyance
en entrant sur le territoire des
États-Unis je réalise que les français
de l'époque à défaut de coloniser
l'immense espace peuvent se déplacer
partout où ils le veulent comme ici à
mitili makinac le zone de commerce et
d'administration sétend jusqu'au cœur
des Grands Lacs et du centre de
l'Amérique à plus de 8 semaines de
navigation de
Montréal en remontant le fil de sa
mémoire un archéologue américain n'en
finit pas de visiter le passé
jusqu'à présent j'ai identifié environ
725 de mes ancêtres en ligne directe
d'origine française ou canadienne
française ils viennent de 120
différentes communes de France mes
ancêtres sont originaires de ce vaste
demi-cercle qui va du nordest jusqu'au
sud de la France est-ce que la plupart
des autres immigrants français viennent
aussi de ces 120 communes de cet
arc oui c'est en effet de cet arc que
vient la majeure partie des immigrants
français qui sont venus en
Nouvelle-France
à lui seul semble reli à tout le passé
de la Nouvelle France il vie à la
mémoire francoindienne de
l'Amérique devant maison qui B le lac
Michigan lui et son épe en un clin d'il
revient cour des
[Musique]
bois
réit estour siette oui oui oui et votre
épouse
aussi vous aussi vous vivez comme ça ce
ce moment de l'histoire de l'Amérique
yes c'est exactement comme ça c'est une
une autre vie
mais je veux euh
entrer dans une autre siècle mais la
plupart de nos
reconstitutions historiques sont avec
notre famille c'était plutôt personnel
pas en
public alors j'ai passé une vingtaine
d'années à rechercher et à recréer la
plupart des objets du quotidien des
population autochton avant l'arrivée des
outils français et pendant 10 ans tous
les étés avec ma femme et mes deux fils
on a mené ce que nous appelions des
recherches d'histoire
vivante
et l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
nous avons expérimenté ces recherche
d'histoire vivante c'est que nous
voulions comprendre de l'intérieur le
mode de vie autochtone et comment il
avait changé avec l'arrivée des objets
français chaque année nous
accomplissions un certain nombre de
tâches avec des outils autochtones puis
nous répétions le même travail avec des
outils français pour les comparer les
amindiens utilisaient ce type d'outil
pendant des milliers d'années et les en
arrivant on vu ces outils et leur ont
dit on peut vous fabriquer les mêmes
mais on va vous les fabriquer en acier
ils ont donc produit le couteau
croche je trouve fascinant d'essayer de
comprendre à partir d'une vision
autochtone comment l'arrivée des
nouveaux outils français peut être
ressenti à la fois comme quelque chose
de magique et de
pratique en conviant dans l'timité de sa
collection privée
Tim me fait découvrir avec grande
modestie son incroyable trésor tout
entier dédié à la période
[Musique]
franco-indienne il y a ici tout ce qui
touche à la vie quotidienne des
autochtones et des français de la région
des Grands Lacs en gros entre le milieu
des années 1600 et
[Musique]
citoyen des États-Unis Timothy Kent ne
cesse d'en explorer l'histoire française
pour qu'elle soit un jour
[Musique]
reconnue
si la fondation de la ville de Détroit
en 1701 par l'officier Lamot cadiac est
admise depuis son origine l'histoire de
la naissance de Chicago a mis bien plus
de temps à être
[Musique]
reconnu la capitale de l'état de
l'Ilinois fut en effet fondée par
Jean-Baptiste point du sable un français
de
couleur fils de marin breton par son
père et africain par sa mère point du
sable s'installe ici en
1779 mais il faudra attendre presque de
siècles pour que l'histoire se souvienne
qu'un homme noir est le père de
Chicago Jean-Baptiste point du sable est
le premier à établir les bases
économiques et commerciales d'une ville
devenue aujourd'hui la 3è métropole des
États-Unis avec ses 10 millions
[Musique]
d'habitants
les États-Unis d'aujourd'hui défilent
dans ce que fut le monde franco-indien
d'hier le long de la route des fleuves
au confluents du Mississippi et du
Missouri les français de l'époque
installent leur ferme sur cette terre
accueillante et fertile que le
gouvernement de la nouvelle-fance nomme
le pays des
hinois
tout ce pays est découvert ce sont de
vastes prairies non seulement la terre y
est propre à porter le froman mais elle
n'a encore rien refusé de tout ce qui
est nécessaire à la nourriture de
l'homme le climat y est fort doux et
l'air y est bon les Français sont ici à
leur aise ils ont des bêtes à cornes et
des volailles les inois d'Amérique de
leur côté d'un naturel doux et de tout
temps très affectionnés au français
travaillent à la terre à leur manière et
sont fort laborieux 20 octobre
1721 le cimetière du village de
saintjnevève se souvient lui aussi qu'en
plein cœur du Missouri battait un cœur
français et que pendant presque 300 ans
les gens d'ici ont maintenu seul contre
tous en plein centre des États-Unis la
langue et la culture du pays des
hillinois jusque dans les années 80 les
anciens de saintjn viève parlaient
encore français aujourd'hui ils ne sont
plus là mais c'est en les écoutant que
Denis stromat musicien et historien de
son peuple a maintenu le flambeau de la
mémoire sa femme et lui sont aujourd'hui
les seuls et les derniers francophones
du Missouri
[Musique]
français
tout le monde on a passé tout le monde
par le français au aujourd'hui c'est pas
comme ça il
est presque à la fin c'est le problème
parce que on continue à jouer jouer la
musique mais difficile de continuer avec
la musique parce que tu es un monde
d'anglais ici dans l'Américain j'aiapis
le français avec avec
l'école dans l'école mais ma grand-mère
parle français mon grand-père aussi elle
parle le français mais ma mère elle ne
parle pas mais elle peut comprendre
ouais elle peut comprendre sa grand-mère
elle a aidé avec sa français aussi parce
que moi j'ai la chance de parler avec sa
grand-mère grand-père et moi moi j'ai
qui est d'cien et et indien aussi avec
avec la famille de mon père euh donc
tous mes
ancestres joué la violence aussi on pe
jou si tu veux juste un petit pièce des
vieilles chansons s'appelle la Guillon h
et c'est une chanson qui est d'ailleurs
n'existe plus en en France et elle
existe uniquement ici dans le Missouri
et c'est vous qui maintenez cette
tradition française dans le missouris et
vous êtes les derniersou ouais ouais ça
vient ouais ça venu de la France plus de
400 ans passés mais ça existe toujours
ici mais je t' dit ça existe pas
euh en la France je je connais pas
pourquoi
[Musique]
mais
la pour la
dernière si vous voulez nous
don si vous vou
nous on le sur
le pas
grandchose
pas
[Musique]
grandchose si vous
vou et son épouse Jenifer se produisent
sur scène seul ou en compagnie d'un
groupe de musiciens créol le plus
souvent devant un public exclusivement
anglophone qui ne comprend pas le
français mais du Missouri à l'Indiana de
l'inois au
de saintj VIè à portage des sou il joue
chante et continue de faire vivre le
pays des
in c'est pas une musique
commerciale par exemple
donc ça c'est la raison j'aime jouer ça
parce que c'est c'est pas comm g ouais
la musique des gens ex
[Musique]
exactement je pense que cette musique
est très
importante elle est l'exemple même d'un
endroit où la culture française la
musique française et la langue française
se sont mêlé au cœur des
États-Unis on croit toujours que la
culture française c'est uniquement
implanté au Québec ou en Nouvelle-Écosse
ou encore en Louisiane et ce que l'on ne
sait pas c'est qu'elle s'est implanté
ici
aussi et à partir d'ici de Saint-Louis
de saintje VIè ou de cap Girardo c'est
le fleuve Missouri qui a transporté
cette culture vers l'ouest vers le
Kansas l'owa le Nebraska le
woming la culture française répu jusqu'à
l'océan Pacifique et vous savez
l'histoire américaine a toujours été
d'avancer vers l'ouest mais la culture
française l'histoire française aux
États-Unis ce n'est pas d'avancer vers
l'Ouest c'est de se déplacer au nord ou
au sud à l'est ou à l'ouest l'hoire
française c'est se laisser porter par
les fleuves et les
rivières l'esprit de l'Amérique
française est à son apogé les Français
ont réussi à s'imisser en douceur dans
l'équilibre immuable du monde indien ils
en deviennent une nouvelle tribu qui
fédère les alliance organise le commerce
et fait régner la paix française
profitant de décennies d'entente les
explorateurs d'abord les voyageurs et
les coureurs des bois ensuite continuent
d'apprivoiser la terre d'Amérique tandis
que les Anglais se cantonnent dans l'est
du continent les Français se répondent
pacifiquement vers l'intérieur et for de
quelques milliers d'hommes seulement
s'installent là où les mènent leur
chemin
[Musique]
d'eau à la tête d'une expédition
franco-indienne d'une trentaine d'hommes
l'intrépide explorateur Robert cavaliier
de la salle descend le Mississippi
jusqu'à son embouchure et fonde la
Louisiane au mois d'avril
[Musique]
1682 40 ans après la salle
François Xavier de charlevois se fait le
témoin de l'accueil des Indiens de
Louisiane dans son journal de voyage le
Mississippi commence ici à fourcher
avant de porter ses eau à la mer un
quart de lieu plus avant dans les terres
et le grand village umaou il y a ici
quelques maisons françaises cette nation
nous est fort affectionnée 10 janvier
1722 300 ans après François Xavier de
charlevois je longe moi aussi les
chemins des Bou pour retrouver la nation
oubliée des umaas de Louisiane isolé du
reste des États-Unis dans le delta du
Mississippi les umaas d'aujourd'hui
perpétue l'Amérique des Indiens et des
Français d'hier en venant les saluer
j'éprouve ce sentiment étrange et
profond de remonter le temps et
l'histoire bonjour messieurs dames
bonjour messieurs comment ça va et
écoutez je vais je vais très bien et je
suis très content de vous rencontrer
content de vous rencontrer
plaisir mon cœur est heureux ouais on
aime ça comme du Nouveau Monde vient et
ça veut voir comment VI et Ben et ben
voilà c'est pour ça que que je viens on
est des indi on est des Indiens et
comment ça se fait que vous parlez
français notre PAP ça c'est la seule
langue qu'on connaissait avant qu'on va
à l'école pour parler anglais ouais et
maintenant ça change hein ça
change et vos enfants ils parlent plus
français non non elle la comprend ou
elle parle elle parle h mais ENF c'est
pas tout mais on voudrait que pas on
veut que la langue françaisent on
aimerait ça ouis et comment faire les
enfants il n de ce qu'il veut pas
prendre ouais c'est c'est difficile
c'est difficile ouais il y a pas d'école
ça TR comme non quand va à l'école c'est
veut pas qu' parle français ouais les
Maess comprend pas et c'est pas les
maîesse le pas par les Français h et ça
ce qu' fa ça ça va mourir avec ça va
ou mes deux
çis ilé tout
[Musique]
qu'
après avoir fondé la Louisiane
l'explorateur cavier de la salle
retourne en France pour convaincre le
roi Louis XIV de lui confier une
expédition maritime le 25 juillet 1684 4
vaisseaux et 300 hommes s'embarquent du
port de La Rochelle pour le Nouveau
Monde il transporte avec eux
l'équipement nécessaire à
l'établissement d'une colonie et à la
construction d'un fort sur le golfe du
Mexique pourtant la mission de la salle
vise aussi un autre objectif en
s'approchant du Mexique l'explorateur
français compte persuader les amérindien
dont il parle les langues de s'allier
avec lui pour conquérir les riches mines
d'argent de la nouvelleesagne le 17
janvier 1685 la salle pénètre au Texas
et s'enfonce à l'intérieur de terres
hostiles pour fonder le fort
[Musique]
sa-louis
l'un des objectifs du roi Louis XIV en
envoyant la salle en mission dans cette
partie du nouveau monde était de savoir
comment la France pourrait prendre
possession des mines d'argent de la
nouvelleesagne l'Espagne tirait
d'énormes bénéfices de l'exploitation
des mines d'or et d'argent du Nouveau
Monde et Louis X en rêvit et la salle
était donc en reconnaissance pour savoir
s'il était possible de s'approprier ces
mines
d'argent
pour moi ce qu'il y a d'absolument
extraordinaire c'est que pendant une
dizaine d'années le contrôle du nouveau
monde entre la France et l'Espagne se
cristallisait sur ce morceau de terre et
lorsque les Espagnols ont appris qu'une
colonie française était en train de
s'installer ici la couronne espagnole a
ét absolument
terrifié il existe des documents
officiels qui montrent que les Espagnols
avent vraiment peur de perdre une grande
partie de leur possession du Nouveau
Monde au cas où les Français se
maintiendrai ici d'ailleurs si nous
avons aujourd'hui au Texas un
extraordinaire héritage hispanique nous
devons indirectement à la salle car sans
la présence française les Espagnols ne
seraient peut-être pas venus ici
imaginons que la salle est réussie nous
auriion aujourd'hui un extraordinaire
héritage
français l'aventure du Texas prend fin
le jour de Noël
1688 de fa de la Nativité les Indiens
kangkawa qui vivent autour des Français
font mine de pactiser avec la garnison
du force Saint-Louis avant de l'attaquer
et de la massacrer jusqu'au dernier le
drame du Texas n'entame pas la puissance
de la nouvelle-fance mais il en
soulligne les faiblesses trop peu
nombreux trop éparpillés les Français
savent que tôt ou tard ils seront
confrontés à la réalité numérique d'une
nouvelle Angleterre 20 fois plus peuplé
la guerre éclate en 1754 elle durera 7
ans
contrairement au plan britannique les
Français mènent l'offensive soutenu par
les alliés amérindiens les opérations de
gueria déstabilise un adversaire formé
aux guerres européennes les victoires se
succèdent mais peu à peu la puissance
des renforts anglais prend la mesure de
la vaillance des miliciens Canadiens et
des troupes franco-indiennes abandonné
par la métropole après plusieurs mois de
siège Québec tombe en septembre
1759 le traité de Paris signé le 10
février 17 3 marque la fin de la guerre
de 7 ans et de la
nouvelle-fance c'est précisément le
moment que choisit le chef utawé Pontiac
pour fédérer les nations indiennes des
Grands Lacs et de l'AO reprendre
l'offensive attaquer les forces anglais
et affirmer sa fidélité au roi de
France la révolte de Pontiac enflamme le
centre du continent lesff tombe un à un
détroit est assiégé mais la réaction
anglaise met bientôt fin au dernier
soubressau d'une Amérique indienne qui
perd toute existence politique avec la
fin de la
nouvelle-fance à partir du régiment
anglais l'histoire change complètement
il y a plus cette cette espèce de de de
d'échiquier politique qui faisait en
sorte que le l'amindien avait un rôle
important à jouer la disparition de la
Nouvelle-France a défait par le fait
même l'importance politique amèindienne
l'histoire a changé basculé complètement
on a commencé à faire une histoire
beaucoup plus
[Musique]
blanche est-ce que les Américains
connaissent cette partie de leur
histoire la plupart d'entre eux non je
pense que cela est en grande partie d à
qui fut le vainqueur de la guerre de 7
ans et parce que les anglo-saxons ont
gagné cette guerre et qu'ils se sont mis
à diriger ce territoire qui est
aujourd'hui devenu les États-Unis et le
Canada ils ont d'une certaine manière
contrôler le contenu de notre
[Musique]
histoire je suis venu ici pour rétablir
la vérité d'une histoire presque
inconnue ou français métis Canadiens
sans mêl ou indien blanc tous reliés à
une même culture qui mêle le violon les
fleuves et l'aventure sèment leur langue
et leur mode de vie aux quatre coins de
l'Amérique juste avant que le rouleau
compresseur d'une autre Amérique fasse
voler en éclat l'esprit des coureurs des
[Musique]
bois
les Français ne furent que quelques
dizaines de milliers à traverser l'océan
pour arrimer leur destin au rêv d'un
nouveau monde ils sont aujourd'hui plus
de 200 millions plus de 20 millions
d'Américains d'origine française qui
vivent au Canada et aux États-Unis
certains ne parlent plus leur langue
mais tous se souviennent que la France
un jour a aimé cette
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
terre et moi je suis très fier de cette
histoire et je suis très fier de cette
culture très fier de cette musique et je
veux qu'elle survive parce que c'est
important on peut pas avoir un peuple
sans une culture il peut pas y avoir de
culture sans une langue pouvez pas avoir
non plus une langue si elle n'a pas de
musique parce que la musique elle-même
c'est une langue un langage cette langue
française que j'ai apprise je voudrais
la transmettre pour au moins encore une
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
génération
[Musique]